a final day of U.N public hearings on
Israeli rights abuses are being held at
the United Nations in Geneva the
commission is examining the allegations
of both Israeli and Palestinian
authorities part of the inquiry is
focusing on the killing of Al Jazeera
journalist Sharina buaklay who was shot
by Israeli forces in the occupied West
Bank last year al-shazir arabic's
Jerusalem bureau chief walida Murray has
testified
was killed by Israeli Army fire while
reporting on the ground about an Israeli
military raid on a refugee camp in the
city of Janine in the occupied West Bank
money I I witness his accounts and
independent investigations have
concluded that the gunfire aimed at
abuakli and other reporters came from
Israeli soldiers and that the
journalists were disability
targeted despite wearing distinctive
breast signs on their exists and helmets
was shot in the back of her head and
rushed to a hospital where she was
declared dead days later at her funeral
procession Israeli police attacks the
mourners who attended beating them with
battles the deliberate
targeting of journalists during armed
conflict constitutes a war crime
moreover under international law Israel
has an occupying power is obliged to
protect occupied people including
journalists
well let's bring emilu in Qatari he's
the commissioner of this United Nations
inquiry on the occupied Palestinian
territory including East Jerusalem and
in Israel that's its official name he
joins us now from Geneva so as regards
the killing of our colleague Sharina
buaklay what did you take away from
today's hearing
well this is part of a second set of
hearings we are having the commission
looking at uh the closure of Civil
Society space in the occupied
territories and in Israel um and we've
been hearing from Human Rights Defenders
activists women human rights Defender
journalists and part of our work was to
look at the
killing of journalists and we have big
we have obviously focused in on
today's hearing we had evidence from Al
Jazeera uh journalists themselves and
we've also spoken to Sherry Nago of his
family we are gathering evidence uh what
we can and at an appropriate time we
will disclose the evidence
to the Human Rights Council the U.N
General Assembly the international
criminal court so it's part of an
ongoing procedure
okay what else what else today
um
did you take what else did you take away
from today and that you'd like to share
with us because as you mentioned it's uh
not just this commission is not just
about shireen's killing it's also about
the shrinking space for civil society uh
in Palestinian territories in Palestine
and human rights abuses generally
yes what we've been hearing is very
disturbing uh it it appears that uh and
you know some of the hearings we had
were closed hearings because of the
sensitivities of those who testified and
threads to them their and their life uh
what we've been hearing is very
disturbing that in the past
uh there's been an escalation of uh you
know the closure of Civil Society space
both by the Israeli authorities by the
Palestinian Authority by the de facto
Authority in Gaza and there have been
there are more and more cases of of
arrests of detentions of torture of uh
particularly targeting let's say lgbti
activists targeting cultural activists
um and in human integrating treatment
and so we are in the process of
compiling all this information which
will be presented to the U.N Human
Rights Council in June this year but
what we heard uh is is very very
disturbing how do you expect this work
will be used and acted upon
well part of our work is of course
investigative and we are as we collect
the information we are making it
available through
also to judicial bodies you will know
that our report to the general assembly
last year in October had made a
recommendation that that the general
assembly refer the matter to the
international court of justice which it
has and we are we are they are taking up
the case that we are waiting for the
verdict on what is the legality of
occupation our report concluded that
occupation has become permanent we are
also asking the the ga has also asked
the international court of justice to
to lay out what are the responsibilities
of third States in in this case what are
the responsibilities in terms of
uh armed support in terms of trade so
that's our ongoing work when whatever we
come up with we are going to make it
available to all judicial bodies
including uh countries where there is
universal jurisdiction so that's it's an
on it's an ongoing mandate which allows
us to also look comprehensively at the
issue both historically and
geographically because we are the first
Commission of inquiry that's been tossed
to also look inside Israel and we are
doing that
thank you for joining us on the program
today